no
[Música]
mi miedo no es grande a lo largo de mi
vida y desde chiquita siempre fue perder
las personas que amo esta sensación de
despertarme y no volverlas a ver me paro
de la cama durante muchísimas noches
hasta hace unos años
en especial me acuerdo de una cuando
tenía nueve años mis papas salieron a
cenar y me acuerdo como me quedé con el
corazón en la mano con muchísima
ansiedad viendo cómo se cerraba el
portón de mi casa
me duermo me despierto a mitad de noche
con mi me llaman apagan su voz
y no otra cosa más que pararme y
recorriendo en aquella oscuridad a mi
casa a su cuarto y meterle las manos a
su cama a ver si ya están de vuelta como
ir tocando sus piernas y cuando llegó a
la altura de la cabeza este les abro las
sábanas con esta necesidad de ver que
estuvieran a salvo
quince años después me enamoro
y me caso con mi gran amor charro
el día que lo conocí
supe que era el no sé si les ha pasado
que como cuando conoces estas personas
que sientes como una conexión inmediata
como cuando empiezas a platicar con
ellos sientes que como si lo hubieras
conocido desde hace muchísimo tiempo nos
enamoramos por minutos
nunca nos soltamos la mano siempre creí
en sus sueños en la manera de vivir en
su risa en la manera como se comportaba
con todo tipo de personas pero nunca
dejaba de ser él y me enseñó a creer en
mí y en mis propios sueños
me enseñó en su día a día que no había
imposibles que todo estaba en la cabeza
y les prometo que era chistosísimo ver
cómo hacía circo maroma y teatro pero
todo lo iba logrando todo lo que se iba
proponiendo
tenía esta gran capacidad de sacarme la
mejor carcajada de mi peor enganche a lo
mejor no tratar los loquitos de amor el
uno por el otro
pero este miedo que les conté al
principio sería más latente que nunca y
funcionado de la misma manera que cuando
yo tenía nueve años me seguía
despertando con que llama empapada en
sudor
le seguía aplicando la misma que mis
papás aún estando a mi lado yo seguía
levantando las sábanas con esa necesidad
de ver que estuviera a salvo
ahora mi miedo era perderlo a él la tara
van dos cosas me aterraba perder a las
personas que amo y caminar está en esta
vida sin ellos sin volver a escuchar su
risa su voz y la segunda era quiero
hacer de mí con tanta tristeza a la hora
que me dijeran que algo les hubiera
pasado porque yo siempre crecí oyendo de
la tristeza evadiendo la como
crecí creyendo que ponerle la cara a la
cara bonita a las situaciones difíciles
era la manera de salir de ellas
pero nunca como tratando siempre con
esta típica frase de todo va a estar
bien era una manera de tapar estos
sentimientos profundos y dejando y nunca
viéndola la tristeza cara a cara
días antes de cumplir un año de casados
con todos los años por delante viviendo
esta parte de nuestra relación más
conectada más que nunca
es el lunes charro
se levanta y se va a trabajar
y en camino a su trabajo
llega una camioneta se le cruza y es
interceptado por un grupo armado
mata a su socio que es la persona que
iba manejando la charla lo bajan de la
camioneta
se los suben con ellos
y nunca más lo volveremos a ver
la vida nos separa de una manera
desgarradora
pasamos el primer año sin ninguna
noticia
nunca nos pidieron ni me dio peso de
rescate por su vida
yo por mi parte
viví ese gran miedo
era este día a día segundo por segundo
desde el minuto que supe lo que había
pasado esta incertidumbre tan oscura
como la que nunca me había confrontado
la vida
esta ansiedad de despertar y pensar que
estás viviendo esta pesadilla de que no
sabes dónde está quién se lo llevó y
quién lo tiene si está comiendo si está
vivo o si no está es eso paralizante que
no te deja ni pensar ni para adelante ni
para atrás y muchísimo miedo miedo a
pensar en lo peor
hicimos todo todo lo que estuvo a
nuestro alcance todo movimos cielo mar y
tierra a través de la fiscalía a través
de un grupo privado en el cual su
familia y mi familia y todos los que
estábamos aquí confiamos plenamente
porque había sacado a personas de
situaciones muy complicadas
verdaderamente yo tenía esta necesidad
de buscar lo bajo piedras de irme en mi
camioneta a todos los pueblos donde me
decían que había posibilidades que lo
podían tener abrir casa por casa bodegas
terrenos todos los lugares donde hasta
encontrarlo llegue ir a ver todo tipo de
videntes con tal de que me dijeran que
seguían percibiendo su energía vil viva
la verdad de las cosas es que el tiempo
seguía corriendo y los expertos me
decían que ya no es o sea que esta
situación ya no se presentaba como un
secuestro por lo que charro pasó a ser
con todo el dolor de mi alma uno más de
los 37 mil 485 desaparecidos que hoy hay
en nuestro país
yo no creo en las casualidades
y estoy segura que el universo la vida y
me encanta pensar que hasta el mismo
charro fueron mandando señales super
claras para yo poder seguir caminando en
este proceso que me estaba costando la
vida y esta mañana estaba en mi
departamento literal haciendo cambio de
ropa porque todavía seguía viviendo con
mis papás
esta mañana llegan y me tocan a la
puerta abro y esta vecina que hace
muchísimo tiempo no veía voltea y me
dice oye lidia este vengo a preguntarte
que hace mucho tiempo no veo las
camionetas ahí abajo este y me interesa
tu departamento para mi mamá y quiero
saber si está todo bien y voltea y mueve
yo creo que me dio la cara hecha pomada
me dice pero estás bien
igual bueno ya no sé qué fue que me hizo
abrirme y compartirles la situación en
la que estábamos metidos viviendo
al finalizar volteó y le borda cara
completamente desencajada lágrimas que
no bajan de su cara y me dice no pobre
pero yo vivir la misma situación que tú
su esposo estaba desaparecido con la
única diferencia que ella llevaba 11
años esperándolo minuto a minuto a que
un día abriera la puerta y regresará y
para mí eso fue una epifanía porque es
cuando me doy cuenta que
charro jamás hubiera querido eso de mí
para mi vida
y que en el espejo que yo necesitaba
para verme y reflejar me y volver a
elegir que yo tampoco quería eso en mí
en mi vida en 11 años porque la verdad
es que yo no podía más con esta
incertidumbre con esta ansiedad de
despertar y no saber qué va a pasar al
día siguiente y al día siguiente y de
voltear a ver el teléfono quieras me
llega la llamado importante que me dé la
pauta a la próxima cita y el próximo
encuentro con nos aquí en contacto y
estar escuchando un bolsón donde un día
me decía de guápiles 9 regresó no te
preocupes todo está bien y yo estaré
haciendo estas ideas mentales y que iba
a regresar y yo ya no podía más con esto
entonces para mí este encuentro es como
muy importante y me doy el permiso de
empezar mi duelo y más que empezar el
duelo de empezar me ha despedirme de
esta idea
y de este proyecto de vida que juntos
construimos
y despedirme de la idea que él ya no va
a regresar
tomando esta decisión
paso al que yo pensé que iba a ser el
reto más complicado de todo mi proceso
regresar a mi departamento tal cual lo
dejamos es el 9 de febrero todo intacto
incluso las sábanas oyen bay
enfrentarme con mi día a día desayunando
comiendo y cenando ahora en esta nueva
soledad cosas tan simples y tan densas
como la cual perfecto este todo todo
bueno todas las mañanas llegaba a
imprimir a la cafetera a las 7 de la
mañana
y el día que regresó y le vuelvo a
prender la cafetera fue para mí como
darme cuenta que él ya no estaba esta
cosa tan tan simple me mandó a la cama
durante dos meses dos días
sacar su ropa
y regresar con sus amigos
vender su camioneta
cerrar su empresa que tanto pasión fue
armando y al final del año hacerle su
despedida y mandarle toda la mejor vibra
del mundo
y a pesar que ni siquiera les puedo
dimensionar los días tan difíciles
en los que me vi metida y en la montaña
rusa en la que estaba viviendo día a día
con muchísima desesperación impotencia
enojo vivi mucha envidia envidia envidia
de ver como la vida seguía corriendo y
como volteaba y toda la gente cercana a
mí seguía celebrando vida a través de
embarazos cumpleaños bodas cualquier
otro tipo de festejo y yo estaba
explorando esta nueva soledad que me
estaba costando la vida
y es cuando estoy en este momento y
cuando menos lo pienso viene un reto
mucho más grande cuando menos lo pensaba
abrirle las puertas a la tristeza
porque yo pensé que ya había pasado lo
peor que yo ya había hecho este palo meo
a la lista de cosas que necesitaba hacer
para poder avanzar
y es cuando llega
esta gran lección que nunca voy a
olvidar
que los procesos no son lineales y a qué
me refiero con esto
al principio de mi proceso yo necesitaba
ser fuerte y bloquear el dolor
necesitaba contenerme para porque
necesitaba seguir avanzando para
sobrevivir pero nunca me dejé caer
y el día que menos lo pensé pasando ya
dos años de la partida de charro
pensando que ya ahorita la vida ya me
depara vayan a subir y subir y subir y
cada día estar mejor llegó a tocarme el
día que paulina mi hermana se casa ese
día que tanto tiempo platicamos juntas
que tanto tiempo pensamos y es hoy día
tan importante para ella
llegó tocarme la tristeza más profunda
con la cual nunca me había conectado
esa tristeza que no tiene horarios que
llega sin avisar que cuando llega no
puedes controlar
me acuerdo que ese día yo no podía hacer
ni siquiera contacto visual con nadie de
las personas que estaban allí porque
literal se me salían las lágrimas por
borbotones y esa tristeza del alma
en la cual nunca había vivido en estos
en estos dos años de proceso llegó a
quedarse conmigo a vivir durante varios
meses hablando todos mis días
y la cosa la tristeza es que siempre
viaja con nosotros siempre digo y
cualquier otra emoción a mí me encanta
pensar que es como cuando yo voy
manejando y traigo todas las emociones
conmigo en el coche como que si la
alegría viniera de mi copilota y atrás
traigo el miedo el enojo la tristeza y
por más silenciosa que venga esta
tristeza
siempre va a haber algo que la vuelva a
hacer detonar y que la vuelva a hacer
brotar
lo que yo aprendió de la tristeza a lo
largo de estos ya casi cuatro años
es que para sanarla hay que sentirla y
vivirla en la vulnerabilidad está la
sanación y que nuestro auténtico dolor
está a la salida y que cuando esta
tristeza llega y que llega como me llegó
el día de la boda de paulina mi hermana
o como me llegan me ha llegado en
muchísimas ocasiones es más grande que
tú es como que si tomara posesión tu
cuerpo porque verdaderamente lo toma y
me encanta ahora lo pienso que más que
una experiencia física eso es un perdón
más que una experiencia emocional es una
experiencia física porque te duelen
todas partes de tu cuerpo me acuerdo que
yo sentía este dolor en los brazos en el
alma en el pecho en toda parte de sus
cuerpos porque está tristeza se queda
sumergida y hoy creo y me encanta la la
chamba que tienen las lágrimas hoy creo
que estas lágrimas que salen de nuestros
ojos son estas burbujitas mágica
sanadora y me encanta pensar que cada
lágrima que sale de nuestros ojos es una
que se está regenerando de dolor
y la verdad es que es bien fácil brincar
y evitar la tristeza a través de
antidepresivos ansiolíticos y hoy les
puedo decir qué
en este proceso
envalentone y me la venta pelo o sea
nunca me tomé ningún tipo de este tipo
de medicinas o gotas porque entendí y
elegí que solamente vienen a alentar el
proceso y me encanta pensar en que estos
son como
como que esta tristeza viene sumergida
y lo que pasa con las gotitas solamente
vienen a esta tristeza se queda tan
sumergida en nosotros
que siempre se queda ahí y cuando tú te
echas la gotita pum parece que como que
si esta tristeza te haya desaparecido
pero lo que no sabes es que cuando te lo
dejas tomar esta tristeza llega con
mucho más fuerza con mucho más vigor y
con mucho más necesidad de salir porque
siempre queda ahí guardada y si no las
es como si las raíces quedan intactas
guardadas
gracias a que me conecte con esta
tristeza tan profunda
se me abrieron puertas como nunca lo
imaginé
me conecté como nunca con la creatividad
con la vida a través de las plantas esos
domingos que me costaban sangre sacar
adelante mi refugio serán los viveros
hoy trabajo con plantas
soy paisajista hago jardines y amo mi
día a día ambos lo que hago
ese miedo que me
que me despertó durante muchísimas
noches hoy se volvió en nigrán mi gran
maestro entendí que ese miedo no te
acaba por matar sino por fortalecer
la vida es asombrosa y lo que un día
duele terriblemente a quien lo ves esa
salida del túnel al día siguiente estás
del otro lado ya saliste y todo termina
por pasar
esta pérdida que tuve que me dolió hasta
el alma
me llevo al encuentro más grande que he
tenido en mi vida
conmigo misma
encontrarme con gente que me sostuvo con
gente que me ayudó con tanto amor con
gente que me llevó a confiar otra vez en
la vida desde el minuto que todo se me
desmoronó hasta que hoy estoy aquí
parada contando la con mi familia con
mis papás con mis hermanos que sacaron
todo todo y que voy a estar eternamente
agradecidos con ellos
con mi intuición con
abrazar mi soledad que tanto miedo me
dio con mi fuerza interior que yo ni
siquiera sabía que era tan grande
abrazar la historia tal cual como fue
con charro porque hoy ya no me peleo con
el plan de mi alma
hoy sé que todo lo que vivimos es un
plan divino perfectamente orquestado
para sanar y para subir este nivel de
conciencia
la pérdida de quien más duele
profundamente pero hoy creo que duele
mucho más pelearse con la realidad
hoy elegí no ser víctima de mi historia
con todo el amor con toda la fuerza y
con toda la voluntad
aprendí a vivir a volver a confiar en la
magia de la vida a reír a volverme
emocionar a lo que hoy le llamo
supervivir no solo sobrevivir todo
gracias a que me atreví a sentir gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]